[Musik]
ich werde mich nicht um eine
kanzlerkandidatur bewerben
ich führe so wie ich das angekündigt
habe den prozess um zu einem
kanzlerkandidat oder einer
kanzlerkandidatin der cdu der union
gemeinsam zu kommen weiter von vorne
gerade mal 14 monate war sie im amt
heute der überraschende rückzug von
annegret kramp-karrenbauer der die
zeiten noch stürmischer macht für cdu
und große koalition
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
das experiment kanzlerschaft und cdu
vorsitz zu trennen ist gescheitert das
hat mit fehlender macht für die
vorsitzende zu tun
wird zu wenig einfluss im schatten der
kanzlerin es hat aber auch zu tun mit
der weitgehend glücklosen und manchmal
instinkt losen amtsführung von annegret
kramp karrenbauer selbst wofür steht sie
was hat sie erreicht wo ist sie
gescheitert
die bilanz einer kurzen aber extrem
fordernden zeit im höchsten partei abend
zieht achim flora cdu-parteitag im
november die vorsitzende keine zwölf
monate im amt und schon mit dem rücken
zur wand sie muss die machtfrage stellen
nicht der weg ist den ihr für den
richtigen halt da lasst es uns heute
aussprechen und dann lasst es uns heute
auch beenden die internen kritiker damit
überrumpelt die partei geht mit noch mal
gut gegangen aber mit schrammen ein
gutes jahr zuvor
annegret kramp karrenbauer setzt sich
gegen merz und sparen durch die
merkel-vertraute wir cdu-vorsitzende
erst ministerpräsidentin dann
generalsekretären nun an der spitze der
union alles läuft nach plan für ak doch
dann verlässt sie schnell das glück
erste panne ein vater witz bei einer
karnevalsveranstaltung erlöst empörung
aus a kk muss sich rechtfertigen
kurz vor der europawahl erschüttert der
youtuber rieso die cdu die vorsitzende
schwaig zunächst und sorgte anschließend
für irritation sind eigentlich regel aus
dem analogen bereich und welche regeln
gelten eigentlich für den digitalen
bereich wunsch nach zensur ein
missverständnis sei es gewesen erklärt
sie später die europawahl im mai wird
zur klima war kaka und cdu ohne
antworten das ergebnis miserabel
zwei monate später kramp karrenbauer
wird überraschend
verteidigungsministerin trotz mehrfacher
beteuerungen als cdu-vorsitzende kein
ministeramt anzustreben
bei den landtagswahlen im herbst folgte
absturz der union unter ihr minus 7,3
prozentpunkte in sachsen minus 7,4 und
brandenburg minus 11,8 in thüringen und
kanzlerin trauma ende 2019 auch nur noch
sehr wenige zu nach 14 monaten als
cdu-vorsitzende zieht annegret kramp
karrenbauer nun zurück nach 14 monaten
mit wenigen erfolgen aber vielen pannen
und versäumnissen
und in berlin begrüße ich annegret kramp
karrenbauer guten abend hallo genannt
ihr rückzug heute kamen überraschend
auch für ihre eigene partei haben sie zu
wenig rückhalt gespürt wenn ich hab mir
schon eine geraume zeit gedanken darüber
gemacht wie wir mit der situation
umgehen dass es in der cdu eine
ungeklärte führungsfrage gibt nämlich
die der kanzlerkandidatur und deswegen
habe ich heute erklärt ich stehe dafür
nicht zur verfügung das wirtschaft mehr
als parteivorsitzende mehr freiheit
diesen prozess jetzt zu führen das werde
ich in den nächsten tagen wochen und
monaten tun
der zeitpunkt ihres verzichts auf
kanzlerkandidatur und dann auch
parteivorsitz der kommt aber unmittelbar
nach den vorwürfen in thüringen wo sie
ihre mission neuwahlen nicht durchsetzen
konnten war das der entscheidende
autoritätsverlust nein zuerst einmal bin
ich in dieser sache mit einem klaren
votum des präsidiums versehen gewesen
sowohl was das thema neuwahlen anbelangt
aber eben auch die tatsache dass ich mit
den thüringern freunden ein weg
vereinbart habe an dessen ende eben auch
neuwahlen stehen und insofern bin ich da
getragen das was wir in den vorgängen
rund um thüringen gesehen haben neben
der eigentlichen politischen frage ist
aber eben diese ungeklärte führungsfrage
und deswegen ist jetzt ein guter
zeitpunkt das zu klären damit ich die
prozesse die es in der partei zu führen
gibt eben auch so führen kann ohne dass
ich mich immer dem verdacht aussetzen
dass ich hier nur im eigenen interesse
unterwegs bin
aber was thüringen ja so kompliziert
macht ist ja dass die parteien mit denen
sie eine zusammenarbeit kategorisch
ausschließen also als steh und linke die
mehrheit haben im parlament eine
mehrheit ohne einer dieser parteien gibt
es nicht wir wollen sie raus aus diesem
dilemma
wir haben ja schon bei dem ersten
versuch der ministerpräsidenten wahl
eine klare linie als bundes partei
eigentlich auch mit den freunden vor ort
vereinbart das heißt wir haben eine
liste von landes projekten definiert wo
wir gesagt haben bei diesen projekten
sind wir in der sind wir bereit auch im
parlament durchaus für mehrheiten mit zu
sorgen und bei einer
ministerpräsidentenwahl gilt für uns
wir wählen weder jemanden von der linken
noch von der afg aktiv mit aber wenn das
zum beispiel auf einem wahlzettel dann
um die entscheidung geht fdp oder linken
kandidat dann enthalten wir uns und
diese linie haben wir heute auch noch
mal bestätigt es ist aber eben auch an
der regierung oder an der abgewählten
regierung in thüringen jetzt zu
überlegen ob man zum beispiel mit einem
dritten kandidaten für ein ganz
gesichert das wahlergebnis von
vorneherein sorgen kann damit man einen
prozess in gang setzen an dessen ende
dann relativ zügig neuwahlen stehen
schauen wir noch mal auf dem bund mit
ihrem rückzug kehrt erst mal um ruhe ein
in die partei aber wohl auch in die
groko wäre es da nicht notwendig sehr
schnell klarheit zu schaffen und nicht
erst im sommer oder sogar erst im
dezember beim nächsten parteitag also
zuerst einmal ist er die frage wieso ist
jetzt eigentlich mehr unruhe geben soll
als vorher denn wir hatten und haben
einen klaren prozess vereinbart der
lautet wir wollen in diesem jahr in
parteitag machen an dem die personelle
entscheidung die inhaltliche
entscheidung und die organisatorische
vorbereitung auf die bundestagswahl
steht der einzige unterschied war dass
es bisher eben neben namen die genannt
werden auch mein name war ich habe heute
gesagt dass ich in dieses rennen nicht
gehe
das gibt mir jetzt sozusagen eine
objektivere freiheit diesen prozess zu
steuern und das werden wir auch tun
jeder kann dazu beitragen dass das ein
ruhiger und geordneter prozess wird wenn
es beim wahltermin für den bundestag im
herbst 2000 21 bleibt dann wäre ihr
neuer kanzlerkandidat oder kandidatin
und dann ja auch parteichef wieder im
schatten der amtierenden kanzlerin
merkel oder rechnen sie mit vorgezogenen
neuwahlen
wir haben für diese legislaturperiode
ganz klar gesagt wir trennen in der cdu
das amt der kanzlerin der
parteivorsitzenden das ist keine
einfache situation für uns ist es
ungewohnt auch das hatten wir bisher so
noch nicht wir haben aber auch ganz klar
gesagt wir stehen zu dieser großen
koalition zu dieser regierung wir wollen
unsere arbeit machen und daran hat auch
der heutige tag nichts geändert
vielen dank annegret kramp karrenbauer
nach berlin
bitteschön das gespräch haben wir kurz
vor der sendung aufgezeichnet
gerade ist bei der spd nach langer
quälender suche ruhe eingekehrt in
sachen parteivorsitz da stolpert der
groko partner cdu in eine krise und will
sich reichlich zeit nehmen sie zu lösen
ob das so funktioniert mit einer
parteichefin auf abruf wird sich zeigen
müssen stabiler steht die berliner
koalition jetzt sicher nicht da es geht
dabei längst nicht nur um personen es
geht um die ganze ausrichtung der cdu
wohin geht die reise wie zerrissen ist
die partei nicole diekmann berichtet sie
geht das ist im moment eine der ganz
wenigen noch verbliebenen gewissheiten
in einer völlig verunsicherten
cdu-parteichefin annegret kramp
karrenbauer glücklos gescheitert gibt
auf mit der aufgabe des parteivorsitzes
durch angela merkel und der trennung von
kanzlerschaft und parteivorsitz haben
wir eine in der cdu geübte praxis
aufgegeben
es hat sich bis in die jüngsten tage
gezeigt dass damit eine ungeklärte
führungsfrage einhergeht ging es
wirklich dermaßen rapide bergab mit ihr
weil die trennung von kanzleramt und
parteivorsitz ein machtvakuum lässt klar
ist thüringen war ein beschleuniger
unverhohlene massive kritik aus kramp
karrenbauers eigener partei von leuten
die sie von anfang an nicht wollten
wiederholen wollen ihre widersacher sie
heute vor der kamera nicht stattdessen
wird schon wieder betont was doch
eigentlich und angeblich längst klar ist
für mich ist es eine frage von haltung
wenn wir eine klare haltung haben und
die werden wir auch in zukunft nach
außen präsentieren
dann sind wir auch geschlossen hinter
dieser haltung diese haltung ist gerade
der typ infrage
in der in gewisser weise am bröckeln
gewesen
ich persönlich sage auch klar und
deutlich ist darf kein zusammenarbeit
mit rechts und mit links geben dort gibt
es für uns brandmauern die lassen wir
auch nicht einreißen nur diese
brandmauern bröckeln längst auch
anderswo sachsen anhalt hier wird
kommendes jahr gewählt hier beantworten
führende cdu nah die frage nach einem
gesprächs verbot mit der afd
so liebe freunde kommt aus eurem 11
in berlin oder in münchen endlich mal
runter kommt raus kommt an die basis und
guckt euch an wie es wirklich aussieht
ich kann keine 25 prozent der
wählerinnen und wähler einfach vor den
kopf stoßen und sagen mit eurem
vertretern rede ich nicht was ihr wollt
was er sagt ist mir völlig egal
die cdu schon bei kramp karrenbauers
amtsantritt 2018 eine tief gespaltene
partei die sich jetzt über die afg noch
weiter zu zerstreiten droht und eine
tiefe kluft zwischen ost und west
offenbart wer soll sie einen heute will
niemand aus einem der lager eine aussage
treffen das partei trauma von erfurt ist
noch zu frisch
ich glaube jetzt kommt es zunächst
einmal darauf an aus der thüringer krise
herauszukommen und das vertrauen der
menschen wieder herzustellen dass sie
ganz sicher sein können dass jede stimme
für die cdu
gleichzeitig eine stimme gegen die afg
ist wohin geht die reise für die cdu
das war mag heute niemand zu sagen es
ist für die partei ein tag der offenen
fragen und der offenen wunden und in
berlin begrüße ich den spd vorsitzenden
norbert walter borjans guten abend
grünen am turn off was bedeutet der
rückzug der cdu-vorsitzenden für die
große koalition zurück zug ist in
gewisser weise besorgniserregend und
zwar nicht deshalb weil bei der beim
koalitionspartner im vorsitz ein wechsel
vorgesehen ist sie wissen das haben wir
auch gemacht und das ist für sich
genommen nicht eine bedrohung der
zusammenarbeit sondern hier steckt etwas
tieferes dahinter die cdu ist in einer
führungskrise nicht er seit heute und
die cdu ist auch in einer
orientierungskrise wie sie sich verhält
gegenüber rechtsradikalen und das was
wir in der letzten woche erlebt haben
das zeigt dass die dämme brechen können
dass in thüringen der damm gebrochen ist
und ich glaube da besteht klärungsbedarf
den haben wir in der letzten woche auch
schon eingefordert die spd hat sich
selbst ja ein halbes jahr genommen um
ihre führungsfrage zu klären jetzt
kündigt die cdu einen längeren
findungsprozess an das staunende
publikum fragt sich wie
handlungsfähig ist eine bundesregierung
die sich vor allem mit sich selbst
beschäftigt naja ich glaube dass wir im
letzten jahr gezeigt haben dass man über
eine längere strecke sich wirklich
intensiv damit beschäftigen kann
wer die partei führt und dass man in
derselben zeit in der gleichen zeit klar
gut regieren kann
sie werden mir nicht sagen können dass
es in der letzten im letzten jahr
während unserer bewerbungsphase nicht
eine reihe von wegweisenden beschlüssen
der bundesregierung gegeben hat also
wenn das bei der cdu jetzt auch so wäre
wäre das nicht das problem
das problem ist die dahinter liegende
krise der partei und die orientierung
die bislang nicht zur kenntnis niemand
weiß in welche richtung die spd mit die
cdu mit einer neuen führung geht es zur
frage mit bitte um eine kurze antwort
sie selbst sind mit deutlicher große
skepsis ins amt gewählt worden
wir werden sie jetzt treu bis herbst
2021 da drin bleiben oder rechnen sie
mit neuwahlen und arbeiten darauf hin
nein wir haben immer gesagt wir müssen
jederzeit für eine neuwahl zur verfügung
stehen aber wir orientieren uns an
inhalten wir bringen die inhalte im
koalitionsausschuss auf den tisch das
haben wir gerade in der letzten woche
sehr klar mit einer sehr klaren haltung
gemacht sind da zu einem ergebnis
gekommen wenn solche ergebnisse halten
dann ist das in ordnung wenn nicht dann
haben wir probleme
vielen dank für das gespräch über einen
mangel an ehrgeizigen kandidaten für die
nachfolge kann sich die cdu nicht
beschweren
vor allem drei namen waren da schon seit
dem rücktritt von angela merkel vor 14
monaten immer wieder gehandelt als mann
der mitte gilt armin laschet
ministerpräsident von nrw ein kandidat
der die partei wieder einen könnte und
auch koalitionspartnern vermittelbar
wäre nur kann dieser mann der cdu auch
neuen auftrieb verleihen abteilung
attacke dagegen friedrich merz
ex-fraktionschef und hoffnungs figur vor
allem für konservative parteikreise
aber würde märz auch die moderaten
kräfte in der partei hinter sich
versammeln
und nicht zuletzt jens spahn bei der
vorsitzendenwahl 2018 zwar deutlich
gescheitert seither aber hat er sich als
gesundheitsminister nicht nur in der
eigenen partei respekt verschafft ist er
der lachende dritte
in berlin zugeschaltet ist die
politikwissenschaftlerin sabine kropf
guten abend guten abend jetzt also namen
im gespräch von denen zwei nämlich
friedrich merz und jens spahn ja schon
einmal in einer parteiinternen
abstimmung verloren haben ist armin
laschet damit gesetzt wenn er antritt
laschet ist zumindest der kandidat der
als mann des ausgleichs und der mitte
gilt und in der migrationsfrage eng zur
kanzlerin gestanden hat nun wird vieles
davon abhängen welches verfahren sich
die partei gibt für die bestimmung des
neuen parteivorsitzenden kommt es also
zum beispiel dazu dass sich die
beteiligten auf einen kandidaten einigen
oder aber geht man in einen wettbewerbs
oder gar in einen offenen wettbewerb
zwischen den beteiligten das würde dann
gewisse unwägbarkeiten nach sich ziehen
welche fehler hat den annegret kramp
karrenbauer aus ihrer sicht selbst
gemacht sie hat eine reihe von
kommunikations pannen zu verzeichnen
und sie hat das darf man nicht vergessen
im november die vertrauensfrage gestellt
also ein instrument bereits verbraucht
dass sie vielleicht hätte noch einmal
anwenden können
thüringen hat ja jetzt gezeigt in den
letzten tagen längst nicht jeder in der
cdu schließt eine zusammenarbeit mit der
afg oder der linken aus wie das ak oder
merkel tun wird das eine frage sein die
die partei spalten kann
sie birgt zumindest erhebliches
unruhepotenzial und die cdu tut gut
daran ihre unvereinbarkeitsbestimmungen
bzw auch ihre frage zur afg zu klären
das schließt nur dann neue machtoptionen
für die cdu und ich denke dass darin
auch in der zukunft eine wichtige frage
liegen wird vielen dank für das gespräch
nach berlin gerne
sie geht und sie bleibt doch ein
bisschen ein rückzug auf raten
annegret kramp karrenbauer hat selbst
die reißleine gezogen wer wann ihr
nachfolger wird ist offen
nach der spd ist auch die cdu in einem
gefährlichen abwärtsstrudel
die krise der volksparteien könnte zur
krise des systems werden
freuen kann das nur die parteien am rand
vor allem die rechtsaußen